- My name's Jason Spires.
It's nice to be able to
use that name because,
for many years, the
only name that mattered
in my life was Mr. K99397 'cause
that was my prison number.
Unfortunately, at a very young age,
I made a stupid decision to sell cannabis,
and I ended up in prison,
and I was never really the type
that was real good at school.
Like, I was smart,
but I wouldn't sit around
and wouldn't focus.
Not trying to make excuses,
but my parents had drug addictions.
I probably didn't have the best guidance,
but I still knowingly made my own choices.
So I own up to that, but
when I got to prison,
I had moments in my life
that made me realize
I had a distorted notion
of what success really was,
and fortunately, when I got arrested,
it helped my mother get clean and sober,
and it helped my father
get clean and sober.
So I now had parents that
were actively involved
in trying to do good things for me,
and I decided that I wanted
to improve my education,
and one of the things that I remember is
my mother went online to Khan Academy,
and she would get printed out transcripts
of what the videos were
talking about in math,
and she'd send me the transcripts,
and I'd read over 'em,
and from that, I started
realizing I understand
how fractions work.
I understand math on a deeper level.
I was always good with it,
but now I was getting to the point
where I could actually
perform well with it.
While I was in prison,
I was able to, with Khan
Academy's transcripts,
learn how to do many
of the math procedures
that helped me perform better on the SAT,
and when I got towards
the end of my sentence,
I was able to get to a
work-release program,
which allowed me to go
to community college,
and I had to take the SAT
in anticipation of
transferring to a university,
and I used the Khan Academy SAT prep,
and fortunately, I was
accepted as a transfer student
at Stanford University,
and little did I know that
a year later I would go
to my classroom, and Mr. Khan
would be our guest speaker,
and I got to tell him something
that was very difficult to say
but was the truest words I could think of,
and that was thank you,
and it's not just who he
is 'cause, like he said,
he did nothing personally for me.
It was his organization.
It was having videos that
were easy to understand.
It was being able to learn
knowledge without having to admit
that I'm stupid because
I didn't already know it.
It took away the embarrassment factor
of having to ask someone else,
and so if you're a part
of that organization,
if you're a donor, if you're
Miss Door who gave Mr. Khan
the impetus he needed to
make this actually happen,
thank you because you played a role
in me now being a Stanford
University student
and studying computer science
after being locked up 15 years
without access to technology.
So I appreciate everything
that's been done
for me in my life,
and there's been so many people
that's contributed to it,
but I can honestly say that Khan Academy
and everyone involved
with the organization
and everyone who has supported
its expansion and growth
to other students has
made an impact upon me,
and I can only tell you that
there's so many other people
that have the potential
to make my story nothing
if they can just get their hands
on the ability to learn
the way that I was able to,
which Khan Academy was a part of.